certains il serait prêt ils sont prêts à
venir dans une équipe municipale mais
veulent pas la place de maire
[Musique]
on m'a nommé victor coulage et 73 ans
donc le super de la commune de châtenoy
depuis mars 2008
on savait plus d'un an que je parle en
disant que je vais certainement me
retirer de ce que par l'âge puis dès
c'est un petit peu la place aux jeunes
ça fait plus d'un an que j'en parle
sauf qu'aujourd'hui
la personne qui se présente le 15 mars
le bureau de vote sera fermée consignes
de la préfecture n'ayant aucun candidat
[Musique]
à partir du moment qu'ils hao qu'un
candidat et les services de l'état
vous ne donnez trois mois je pense
jusque fin mai pour réorganiser des
élections municipales
par contre si à la fin
de mode mais aucune équipe n'est élu on
sera certainement rattaché à une autre
comme une chose que je lui ai pas trop
envie en tant qu'ancien maire j'ai pas
du tout envie d'être attaché d'une façon
autoritaire à une autre commune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui la place de maire c'est pas
une place enviable des ressources des
petites histoires et disons que ça
devient ça devient compliqué
qu'aujourd'hui notre société en général
a changé beaucoup changé le
les gens aujourd'hui ils ont des droits
ils n'ont peut être pas forcément devoir
et quelques pas beaucoup maintenant je
ne vienne procédurier parce que il ya
une branche ou une fleur ou à je ne sais
pas quoi une végétation qui a un petit
peu plus importante
les genres et commence et il n'avait pas
entretenu comment se fait-il que sanaa
terriens pas on arrive on arrive
maintenant dans nos villages à avoir une
tension un petit peu
voilà d'où les gens parlent critique
mais n'osent pas ils n'osent pas venir
s'expliquer voilà directement avec les
personnes concernées
ça déplore c'est quelque part un
appartement qu'elle étend si on fait
plus bon vivre
puis bon dans ces villages ils vont
remettre en ville le trt voilà vous
rentrez chez vous fermez la porte depuis
terminé l'aiguillage pour le non c'est
une population vieillissante malgré tout
bien qu'on a de la jeunesse il ya des
gens qui ont construit à des gens qui
arrivent on essaye de par des biais
d'une association
disons de faire vivre le village on a
créé une zone de jeux ou les jeunes
enfants c'est beaucoup apprécié donc on
essaye quand même malgré tout avec nos
petits moyens parce qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup de moyens
on essaie malgré tout de faire évoluer
le village mais c'est pas ça comme vous
le savez on n'a pas de sens technique on
est obligé de tout de tout gérer une
commune comme chaque nom plutôt que de
payer un bureau d'études
rescue de dire ça mais puisque le père
est d'abord un bureau d'études qui va
nous demander 7 à 8 10% je sais pas
exactement
on fait tout nous-mêmes l'eau ont géré
nos temps nous mêmes c'était un automne
en régie communale c'est à dire que
c'est nous mêmes qui recevront les
compteurs et nouvelle cale on voir le
château d'eau c'est vrai qu'au bout de
12 ans aussi un petit peu et puis large
fait faisant que
ce sont 13 ans on a envie de passer un
petit peu la main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir disparaître châtenois sincèrement
ça c'est un crève coeur qui à partir du
disons que moi de mon côté je vais
regarder il ya des jeunes qui sont prêts
à démarrer avec moi et puis peut-être
que durant les premières années
peut-être que quelqu'un éventuellement
quand il a vu un petit peu de manière
que ça fonctionne pour repartir et
prendre la relève quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
oui
[Musique]